[Music]
hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and I'm doing a little
video log of my child's birth my wife
Rebecca is pregnant with our third
little boy and tomorrow morning she's
gonna be induced and we're gonna bring
this little bundle of joy into our
family and I'm I'm really excited and I
just wanted to do a little video log
more for myself and my family than
anything else but figured I'd share it
with you guys as well don't worry I'm
not going to turn this into a health ed
video and keep it all g-rated before I
put the kids to bed today that I decided
to go an interview Tommy and Nathan and
ask him a few questions about their baby
brother can I ask you some questions you
know you are having a baby brother
tomorrow do you know that now where's
the baby right now stomach
hmm yeah that's right that's right yeah
he goes poopoo in mommy's tummy
how big you think he's gonna be how many
how many brothers do you think you
should have three brothers holy and do
you want a sister is there anything you
want to save the baby Jacob yes did you
look at the camera and tell me tell
maybe Jacobs something baby thanks for
letting me interview you
oh excited to have a little brother how
could you think the baby's gonna be ah
he's big he's gonna be a good big
brother
mm-hmm and we're not gonna hit the baby
right hmm Oh Bobby
eat eel big boy Habibi
Oh Tom he's gonna hit the baby high but
you're not gonna hit the baby right hi
guys guys bye well be free for you so
you're gonna punch Robbie if he hurts
the baby all right it's 6:00 in the
morning and we're heading to the
hospital to go have a little baby boy
ready to do the thing I think a big you
going into this hospital a mother of two
little boys you're gonna walk out of
this hospital mother of three little
boys the course 7:30 in the morning and
we are geared up and ready to go for her
more than me my mom did all right Vicki
you excited and we're pretty well
settled on the name right probably let's
make jelly meat I'm gonna make sure it
fits but yeah we're thinking Jacob David
Nicholls right we'll see we'll see we
got to check the merchandise out first
all right so things are going well
Becca's got her IV in the nurses are
very nice and we're gonna get things
crack in here Beck are you ready to do
this yeah apparently you can use the
swivel chair as much as you want and
nobody will stop you so this is
[Music]
you look hot I'm just gonna say this you
know I'm gonna put it out there you
good-looking woman
well it's 8:30 we've got IVs we've got
heart monitors we're just waiting for
the patella ptosis kind of get this
thing going and maybe here by mid
afternoon early afternoon
[Music]
all right it's baby watch 2017 and it's
10:15 here in the Nichols delivery room
and we've started dripping the baby
grease oh yeah this is where it gets
real folks real real baby watch 2017
it's now 11:30 got contractions yeah we
have the truth Sam pumping in yo I'm
suing you what tell us everything you
know well guys the doctors and nurses
we're in here and it's getting serious
the anesthesiologist is coming in we got
contractions things are happening I
promise you I would keep this g-rated so
on that note I am putting the GoPro away
and focusing on my wife here so what you
see is next that I have a little baby
boy blurted is out you're mad berries
are on camera the 7000 I think you beat
Tommy and you're just behind Nathan
maybe Nathan with seven pounds something
seven twelve yes I think you're
somewhere between Tommy and Nathan
little guy seven pounds six ounces of
Awesomeness right there you know Jacob
you look oh you have a pretty normal
sized head Nathan had a freaky head when
he was born you had the big one kid was
all noggin yeah that's probably where
that extra you know six ounces Kim oh
that's a good length the good leg young
man
how you feel babe is cute right there I
[Music]
know it's a cliche but as soon as I saw
that little guy just choked me up just
hit me like a ton of bricks it's my
third time doing it and still still got
me
needles bigger than his purse oh that's
inappropriate that's an appropriate
reaction I tried to stop her but she hit
we have to get rabies shots after we got
attacked by a 30-pound rabid beaver on a
date once how you keep this spark alive
is a perfect baby burrito right there
see none of your feelings come out the
end has to be fed every two hours so I'm
leading by example midnight hanging out
a bit got his first meal and taking this
first nap and they're gonna transfer us
over to the to a new room and hopefully
tomorrow we'll get to see Tommy and
Nathan they'll get to meet their little
brother I am pretty darn tired it's
gonna be a long night
Jacob hold on buddy going for a ride all
right guys so we're in the room where
I'm gonna be staying for a day and a
half so gonna get my bed ready check
this out okay and then we go
there we go that's my bed system the
more today - its baby feeding time
alright my first full day with Jacob
look at that guy
snoozing away pooping good he's peeing
good he's eating oh right and he is so
cute look at him just sleeping away he
was born in a snowstorm apparently he's
got that Alaskan blood so we had a
couple inches of snow last night and he
gets to meet his brothers today I am so
excited to see Nathan and Tommy I missed
it that is a good-looking young boy one
little glitch and thing is Becca's right
leg the numbness hasn't worn off from
the epidural so the doctors are a little
scratching their heads over that so
they're gonna go send her to get an MRI
alright just to check it out make sure
it's nothing serious
probably just something that just needs
to wear off a little bit longer for her
for some reason but go check her out
make sure she didn't bruised her spine
or something getting the epidural so
well Becca just got back from her CT
scan and everything's normal her poor
leg is numb and she's pretty gimpy but
we're just gonna kind of wait and see
it'll probably just go away with
[Music]
I'll let Nathan have a turn here you
hold in the bottom Nathan would you hold
his head gently like this we got to
teach Jacob how to burp he doesn't know
how to burp do you guys know how to burp
[Music]
Jacob do you want to see your brothers
be very gentle very soft and slow yeah
look at that he's got he's got a little
male paddle fold this you miss you guys
we'll be home in a little bit kid we'll
bring Jacob home to stay with us okay
all right buddy I'll see him a little
bit while we're approaching the end of
day two of Jacob joining our family and
he's 25 hours old and he is just cute
and eating and pooping and peeing and
doing all the little things that
brand-new babies should do and he's just
perfect and right now the drama though
is Becca's leg has not gotten better so
she after the epidural she's her right
leg is just dead it's numb she can't
move her foot she can't feel her for
most of her leg is still numb and 24
hours later and the rest of hers fine
now but that one part is that and
everyone's kind of scratching their
heads and not sure what's causing it
there's a few things they've checked out
they had to do a cat scan and it's the
really big nasty things
things aren't it so a specialist is
coming tomorrow neurologist to see and
it's causing some pain too so we're
gonna try to see if the neurologist
can't put his finger on what's wrong and
fix it and
nothing else I'll manage the nerve pain
so but but we're counting our blessings
you have a sweet perfect little baby boy
and a lot of a lot of parents would
trade places with us in a heartbeat for
that and so we are very very fortunate
grabbing your mama's finger just holding
on kind that's pretty precious isn't it
it's so sweet and cute
well hey everyone it's a three in the
hospital here and I actually slept this
morning it felt wonderful that is slowly
recovering her leg is she actually was
able to feel cold today so that's a big
deal for us to see a little bit of
improvement it looks like it's gonna
take a while but and we think she will
get better the neurologist came and
spoke to her and everyone's poking their
heads into kind of ask your questions
because I think it's kind of an unusual
situation but they're gonna give her
something for the pain and it should
work a little bit better than what
they've been giving her in the past and
they're going to give her an MRI if she
doesn't improve in a couple weeks so at
least this week she's gonna have trouble
walking for a while and Wow my sweet
baby my amazonian goddess might be on a
walker for a little bit so we're just
going to adjust accordingly and this
little guy is just perfect as can be
what we're supposed to check out at the
hospital today
tired of sleeping on that couch and just
being back home around familiar things
with your own food and everything sounds
really nice so hopefully we'll be
bringing Jakob home today how's that
oxycodone making you feel Becca's
feeling a little nasty because of some
of the medication they gave her and
there's gonna be a with a physical
therapist it's gonna come and bring her
a walker show her how to use the walker
so as soon as that's done we're gonna
get to go home which I'm pretty excited
about and we'll just have to see what we
can do to make it back as comfortable as
possible and take care of business so
she doesn't have to worry about anything
other than getting better doing good by
the way baby so the physical therapist
was here and Becca has achieved her
orange belt in physical therapy
nice I'm only laughing about this
because you're really doing a lot better
than you were yesterday I wouldn't be
laughing about this if I thought this is
gonna be a long-term thing but everyone
seems to think that this is just a
matter of time from a few days to a few
weeks before she's gonna be all hunter
percent recovered no we're just gonna
roll with it and take care of you and it
sounds like a great reason to pamper you
even more and make you not have to fuss
with the kids for a while well Mama's
got her Walker and knows how to use it
high five
she has seen her on the stairs like a
boss any rate so she's doing better
Jacob here is as cute as ever and I'm
gonna load up the car and we're gonna
take this baby home all right buddy it's
time to check you out sorry you're
sleeping here we gotta get you dressed
hopefully okay yeah now we're gonna
dress you and one of many out
and here he is guys there's Jacob in his
little onesie and if you don't think
that's cute your heart is made of rocks
look at that now that you're all dressed
you look nobody already ready to travel
let's do it all right Becca are you
ready to be in your own house tonight
[Music]
we're gonna stay up all night drinking
or at least helping him drink go for it
[Music]
well Becca we did it we made it you you
did most the hard work but we got our
little baby boy and we are home you know
I'm so excited to walk through that door
with little Jacob and
yeah let the boys really have time with
them you know
you ready Jacob let's do this oh you got
your baby brother here let's let's bring
baby brother inside she's in the car I'm
gonna help her get out here in just a
second all right
you can do it I've never seen a woman in
a walker look so sexy well it's been six
days now since Jacob was born and Mama's
doing a little bit better we've been
home for about three or four days and
every day Becca that seems a little bit
stronger she gets a little bit more
feeling in her leg so we're optimistic
that things will wear off in a couple
weeks but she still needs help getting
up and down stairs you know it's it's
it's a real burden for her but luckily
we have a lot of family around and I'm
taking time off work so it's uh it's
working out okay we're just kind of
using it as excuse for her to take it
easy but a little Jacob here is super
sweet and he has the longest fingers in
the world
look at these fingers yeah look at these
hands
he's got man hands yeah what where's the
other one where's your other one Joe
it's somewhere in here oh look at these
look at those fingers long fingers what
a cutie and he is such a sweet boy oh
you making noises in your pants but at
any rate we've got this sweet little boy
and we are so glad we are so lucky and
here a little bit you'll be seeing more
of Jacob in our videos everyone say hi
to the newest member of the outdoor boys
team
let's go get you some milk bud thanks
for watching we hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you'd like to see more
great videos from the outdoor boys
YouTube channel don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
week and don't forget to hit that Bell
button so you'll get notified when we
put out another great video